[music playing]
He's going to fix it.
Left online 60 Minutes ago.
Are you calling somebody?
What if they answer?
Hey, sweetheart.
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER):
I'm in Ghana watching
two romance scammers at work.
He calls himself the Punisher
and she is Miami Queen.
[kiss noise]
I missed you.
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER):
And to my surprise,
they're scamming men, not women.
How long has it been, baby?
Been a while, right?
Yeah, I know.
But I told you I had
problems with my phone, so.
OK.
You know, I understand.
I still love you.
Sweetheart, let me go
and take a shower, OK?
I'll call you when
I'm done, yeah?
Don't go anywhere.
Just wait for me.
And we're done.
So what just happened here?
You were-- started to
call somebody, right?
And then when he
accepts, if it's a video,
you pass it on to her?
Yeah.
When you're communicating,
he thinks he's communicating
the whole time with her--
Yeah.
--when he's
communicating with you.
Mm-hmm.
And then you're just--
Mine is just look beautiful
and make him feel sweet,
how much I love him.
[music playing]
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER):
Most of romance scamming
is messaging, just typing.
But they've rented
the space tonight
for these occasional
video calls,
hoping to satisfy their clients.
How many people do you
guys know that are scammers?
A whole lot of people.
Oh, my God.
We have-- we have
friends, Hundreds.
Like dozens, hundreds?
Dozens.
All your friends are doing it?
Yeah.
I have friends who
are rich, very rich.
They've built
houses, big, big cars.
Everybody's making money.
[computer sound effect]
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER):
Wiring money, gift cards,
or straight up
cash are preferred.
[text notification sound]
But payment in Bitcoin
is also becoming popular.
[text notification sound]
I'm a female.
I'm using the
profile of a female.
So you're pretending to
be a woman and scamming men.
I'm pretending to be a woman.
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER): It's
easier to get money from men,
he says.
And there are simply more men
using online dating sites.
[eerie music]
And yet, back in the States,
far fewer men than women
report being victims.
And this person
you're talking to,
Michael, has no idea that
you're actually a man in Ghana?
Yes.
I started falling
in love with him.
Not for intercourse or
whatever it is, but you know.
I felt for him.
Right.
Michael is kind-hearted.
I think Michael has
been too good to me.
How much money has
Michael sent you so far?
More than 10K.
More than $10,000 for what?
What do you say?
Renting apartments,
school fees.
Michael knows I'm in
school here in Ghana.
Wow.
OK.
So I do this.
Are you actually calling him?
Yes.
[calling sound]
Where is he?
Virginia.
[call disconnecting sound]
Oh.
So Michael is not online.
Oh, OK.
INTERVIEWER
(VOICEOVER): No dice.
But had Michael
picked up, he would
have seen this video
recording of a young woman.
This video will play
when you answer the call.
But, if you talk,
it doesn't match.
She's not talking.
You see, she's typing.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
So you have the video and
then you're just typing.
Yes.
Where did you get this video?
You buy it online.
Oh, you buy It.
Yeah.
INTERVIEWER (VOICEOVER):
scripts, these videos are part
of a scammer's
professional toolkit,
an underground
industry unto itself.
[calling sound]
[music playing]
Hey.
Hey, honey.
Hey, sweetheart.
Hey.
I love you.
[laughing]
[calling sound]
Hi.
I missed you.
[text notification sound]
[laughing]
[music playing]
(SINGING) No, slack, yeah, uh.
[outro music]